despite the rigid rules of control
inmates push back when officers backs
are turned
inmates gamble run tattoos with
makeshift equipment and make homemade
alcohol behind the lesser offenses
though wise a greater danger homemade
weapons are constantly fashioned
currencies sometimes slips by security
and cell phones are smuggled in weapons
can be used in attacks cell phones can
be used for escape attempts and currency
can be used to bribe officers getting
caught with any of these items
guarantees you a trip to the back of the
prison - another tool of control for
Hays the special management unit or SMU
these are the inmates that have proven
to be a threat to other inmates to
themselves or in some cases a threat to
the very order of the prison itself
Morgan Corley is in the SMU again Corley
might not have the appearance of a
hardened criminal but looks can be
deceiving
yeah I did I did it to the fullest
Morgan Corley used to be a truck driver
but discovered he had a talent for
selling drugs
Carly's hustle was ice smokeable
methamphetamine and what started as
deals over a few ounces soon became
pounds per week making Corley one of the
biggest meth dealers in Georgia the
money got so good and the power I'll
just I started living the lifestyle I
got caught up Corley pled guilty to
racketeering as serving nine years
inside his life of crime though didn't
stop with his conviction he has been to
16 different prisons and amassed more
than a dozen charges behind bars
I bought myself
people doing you know things an
institutional allow I'd do a lot of drug
trade and cell phone for making money I
like to make money making money behind
bars a far-fetched thought requiring an
elaborate network of people
I'll find a guy in the prison that
that's able to move who's like a flat
top award earlier works in the hole who
able to go to every dorm every building
you know on the whole compound and I
have him take it to where it's got to go
and then I have another guy who I have
like a stash guy maybe works in the
kitchen you know like hide in the
freezer or the dogs can't smell enough
you know they never stay down I'll have
a hidden there and as I need it I have
guys go to that guy and get it and take
it a worse got to go and really I'll
just sit back and kind of the rent but
needs to happen you know I'm never gonna
get caught with nothing I got people
that I have selling it holding that you
you know taking care that business for
me I never never put myself in that
champagne Corley fashioned himself as a
chain gang Godfather at the helm of a
prison criminal enterprise now he claims
his days of running drugs and cell
phones have ended but he's back in the
hole again this time for possession of a
fifty dollar bill with no cash allowed
in prison it's incriminating evidence of
illegal activity
you